en el vídeo pasado vimos como la cruz
keynesiana nos puede ayudar a visualizar
que un incremento en el gasto
gubernamental era un desplazamiento en
la línea de gasto agregado planeado de
acá vimos también que este cambio el
cambio en la producción si nos creíamos
pues todas las hipótesis que supusimos
en el vídeo anterior entonces qué cambio
en la producción o bien el inglés
agregado
era más que el gasto gubernamental
entonces puedes decir no no no el
pensamiento keynesiano es muy de
izquierda el gobierno está gastando
mucho dinero y pues la verdad yo soy más
conservador y yo no creo en el
pensamiento keynesiano pero en realidad
puede ser que si creas en él sin
importar si eres de izquierda o de
derecha claro
históricamente el pensamiento keynesiano
ha sido más abusado por la derecha y más
apoyado por la izquierda sin embargo
casi todas las políticas de derecha y
sobre todo últimamente en los eeuu han
estado basadas en un pensamiento
keynesiano pero no se enfocan a
modificar esta variable de acá por
ejemplo cuando la gente habla acerca de
expandir la economía disminuyendo los
impuestos que están siendo keynesianos
porque ver si nos regresamos
la función original si no hacemos esto
de acá y regresamos vamos a tener la g
por acá entonces nada más tenemos la g
original estamos de nuevo en esta línea
naranja que fue el gasto planeado con el
que empezamos entonces podríamos basados
en este modelo de por acá también
desplazarlo hacia arriba disminuyendo
los impuestos entonces si cambiamos los
impuestos a que sean impuestos menos
menos algún cierto delta de impuestos
entonces la razón por la cual esto se va
a desplazar hacia arriba es porque estás
multiplicando toda esta cosa de acá por
un número negativo por menos c1 c1 es la
propensión marginal al consumo si te
acuerdas que estamos suponiendo que es
positiva y hay un menos por acá entonces
si multiplicamos esto por un negativo
que es una disminución por un negativo
estoy acá es un cambio negativo en los
impuestos entonces toda esta cosa se va
a desplazar hacia arriba otra vez y
entonces en realidad nos desplazaríamos
nos desplazaremos en este caso claro
dependiendo de la magnitud del cambio en
impuestos pero nos desplazaremos hacia
arriba y la cantidad
no quiero que quede muy amontonada la
gráfica a ver esto ya que es el gasto
planeado agregado y la cantidad en la
cual nos desplazamos hacia arriba es
este coeficiente de acá hace 1 - c 1 por
menos del tate entonces el cambio la
cantidad que nos movemos hacia arriba es
menos c 1 x menos del dato estamos
suponiendo que el dato es positivo para
de adeveras bajar los impuestos entonces
tenemos ese 1 por del trate porque menos
por menos es más
eso es en cuanto se desplazaría hacia
arriba y claro también es keynesiano si
dices que un incremento de impuestos
disminuye la producción porque si
aumentamos los impuestos si los
aumentamos entonces de repente éste se
hace positivo esto es positivo y
entonces la curva se movería en este
tanto la curva se desplazaría hacia
abajo
de hecho llegaríamos a un nivel menor de
equilibrio del producto interno bruto
entonces esto realmente no es una
distinción entre un pensamiento de
izquierda o bien un pensamiento de
derecha para la política fiscal en este
vídeo y el pasado nada más hemos visto
políticas fiscales verdad por acá
lage era el aspecto del gasto de la
política fiscal y acá late es el aspecto
de impuestos que también es algo fiscal
y así que creo que cualquiera de esos
puede afectar la producción agregada
entonces básicamente te estás adhiriendo
al modelo keynesiano bueno pasemos a
otra cosa una cosa que apenas si
mencioné en el vídeo pasado es que
cualquiera que sea el cambio la cantidad
en la cuál desplazamos esta curva hacia
arriba entonces el cambio en nuestra
producción iba a ser un múltiplo de eso
lo que quiero hacer ahorita es mostrarte
que matemáticamente en efecto es así y
más aún que el múltiple es el
multiplicador que vimos en vídeos
pasados entonces regresamos a la
ecuación original ahorita nos vamos a
poner matemáticos entonces el gasto
planeado vamos a volver a escribir la
formulita pues porque no hace daño
acordarnos de cómo iba pero entonces el
gasto planeando va a ser
a la propensión marginal al consumo por
el ingreso agregado y luego tendremos
que poner todo esto de acá iba a ser el
original no el cambio pero todo esto de
acá vamos a llamarle b para que sea más
sencillo manipular vale entonces a toda
esta expresión de acá le vamos a poner
be y después la podemos sustituir por lo
que vale pero bueno sabemos sabemos que
si una economía está en equilibrio
entonces el gasto planeado es igual a la
producción eso es que la economía está
en equilibrio entonces vamos a hacer eso
vamos a hacer que la economía esté en
equilibrio haciendo que el gasto
planeado sea igual a la producción
agregada que es lo mismo que el gasto
agregado que lo mismo que el ingreso
agregado entonces ahorita ya podemos
despejar nuestro punto de equilibrio
vale entonces vamos a despejar lo que
tenemos que es igual a cero porque más
bien ahorita vas a ver que es algo que
ya vimos y ahora restándose uno de ambos
lados tenemos ya menos de uno a la
izquierda ya la derecha pues claro esto
se cancela verdad
y ya nada más nos quedaría que es igual
a b y luego podemos factorizar podemos
factorizar el ingreso agregado de acá
entonces tenemos por 101 es igual a b y
ahora dividiendo a ambos lados entre 1 -
c 1 entre 1 - c 1 obtenemos esto se
cancela déjame escribir por acá lo que
queda obtenemos aquí es cuando empieza a
sonar el redoble de tambores tenemos que
el ingreso agregado o bien el ingreso de
equilibrio o la producción agregada o el
producto interno bruto como quieras
llamarle va a ser igual a va a ser igual
a 1 entre 1
1 x b recuerda ver a esta cosa de acá
arriba pero ahora qué es esto de acá a
lo mejor te acuerdas de esto si no has
visto el vídeo a lo mejor quieras verlo
el vídeo de multiplicador
pero este 2001 es la propensión marginal
al consumo la propensión marginal al
consumo entonces uno menos la propensión
marginal al consumo es creo que no lo he
mencionado
debería escribir lo por acá para que
conozcas el término entonces ese uno es
igual a la propensión marginal marginal
al consumo entonces por ejemplo si esto
de aquí fuera 30% o punto 3 eso quiere
decir que por cada peso adicional de
gasto disponible entonces voy a gastar
30 centavos de eso pero 1 menos de 11 -
eeuu no lo podemos pensar como la
propensión marginal al ahorro o sea si
voy a gastar el 30% de mi ingreso esto
quiere decir que voy a ahorrar el 70%
esto simplemente está diciendo que voy a
ahorrar 1 -1 si gastó 30 centavos por
peso entonces voy a ahorrar 70 centavos
entonces estoy acá en la propensión
marginal al consumo el denominador es la
propensión marginal al ahorro y luego 1
sobre eso
1 / 1 c 1 que es lo mismo que 1 entre la
propensión marginal al ahorro eso de
allí se ha multiplicado el multiplicador
que vimos en vídeos pasados ya sabes
tomábamos una serie geométrica en la
cual bueno que salía de que yo gastar
algo en un bien o servicio luego esa
persona que lo recibía lo gastaba según
su propensión marginal al consumo que
supusimos que era constante o sea que no
dependía del nivel de ingreso como lo
estamos suponiendo en este modelo de por
acá y entonces luego ellos gastaban un
poco de eso la persona que recibe el
dinero gasta una fracción y luego si
sumamos todos esos gastos y hacíamos la
serie infinita obteníamos este
multiplicador de acá entonces esto es
igual a eso es igual al multiplicador
muy bien entonces por ejemplo si ves que
desplaza se desplaza hacia arriba en
cierta cantidad si se desplaza hacia
arriba cambiando cualquiera de estas
cantidades ya sea la exportación neta o
la inversión planeada si se cambia hacia
arriba o hacia abajo pero bueno no
importa cómo se cambie la cosa es que el
cambio en el producto interno bruto va a
ser
ese mismo cambio multiplicado por el
multiplicador el multiplicador que vimos
en vídeos pasados entonces por ejemplo
si no se hace uno es igual a digamos 0.6
o sea que por cada peso adicional que se
gane entonces la gente va a gastar 60
centavos entonces la profesión marginal
al ahorro un ahorro sería igual a 40 por
ciento van a gastar 40 por ciento de
cualquier peso adicional disponible y
entonces el multiplicador multiplicador
va a ser igual a 1 sobre eso va a ser
igual a 1 entre 0.4 que es lo mismo que
1 entre dos quintos que es igual a 5
medios que es lo mismo que 2.5 entonces
por ejemplo en esta situación acabamos
de ver que ya o más bien layer de
equilibrio va a ser igual a 2.5 por lo
que resulte de esta maraña entonces si
cambiamos b
digamos mil millones de pesos para ser
más concretos digamos que que lo
aumentamos en mil millones de pesos y ya
vemos que hay varias formas de hacerlo
verdad podemos aumentar el gasto
en tales mil millones de pesos o tal vez
podemos modificar todo este término todo
este término incluyendo su signo
negativo haciéndolo menos negativo en
mil millones de pesos o también
aumentando la inversión en mil millones
este cambio de inversión puede ser pues
con una política de impuestos para lo
mejor despreciando los activos más
rápido o incluso si aumentamos la
importación de 3.000 millones falla
cualquier forma en la cual incrementamos
ve en mil millones de pesos va a
incrementar el producto interno bruto en
2.500 millones de pesos en 2.5 veces el
cambio debe entonces podemos escribirlo
así que el cambio de g
también va a ser igual a 2.5 veces el
cambio en b o bien otra forma de
pensarlo escribiendo la expresión así
diciendo que es función de b es mirar la
pendiente de 2.5 así el cambio en cambio
en g entre el cambio en b es igual a 2.5
pero bueno es que todo este circo para
mostrarte que lo que estábamos haciendo
no era magia negra en realidad cuando
hacíamos un análisis visual de la cruz
keynesiana simplemente en el fondo
estábamos hablando de algo matemático
que tenía que ver con el multiplicador
ese multiplicador que estudiamos en
vídeos anteriores